the last section of law that we
translated was an izalith and what we
learned there forever changed the way
that I'll do it going forward back then
I also mentioned the abyss and it's
creatures and just like in izalith
there's far more of these creatures than
the English lets on first and most
importantly the primordial serpents so
the very name primordial serpent is
perhaps more accurately translated as
world serpent which is a really overt
reference to the legendary world serpent
jörmungandr of Norse mythology yeoman
Gander is a child of Loki he's a sea
serpent that is so giant that his body
in circles the entire Earth actually
Chester also refers to the primordial
serpents as giant snakes calling them
Orochi in the Japanese text so they're
the biggest snakes in from software
history no no they were the imagery of a
snake eating its own tail is an example
of an Ouroboros a symbol of wholeness
infinity the universe the cycle of life
death and rebirth and these are all
concepts that fit really neatly with the
so called primordial serpents because
they're obsessed with the cycle of the
world and I think it's fair to take
issue with the word primordial this
implies that they've existed since the
beginning of time but a couple of item
descriptions actually suggest that
serpents are derivative of ancient
dragons no instead these world serpents
are better seen as creatures that
represent and understand the logic of
the world I am the primordial serpent
dark stalker calf I can guide thee and
illuminate the truth I am the primordial
serpent King Sica frapped close friend
of the great Lord Gwyn chosen Undead I
wish to elucidate your fate
they are elders sages who take up the
role to inform and advice respected for
their profound knowledge of the universe
even if cars and frampt interpret that
knowledge differently Kath
the serpent found after defeating the
four kings beliefs Lord Gwyn resisted
the course of nature and when Kaif talks
about the quote-unquote course of nature
he's perhaps better translated as saying
the world's logic in souls this world's
logic was supposed to be the fall of
ancients to light and the fall of light
to dark this is the logic of the world
and calf and his ilk help us because
they've come to understand that reality
at its core
therefore cars retinue probably weren't
always aligned with the dark
in fact calf when he talks he talks
about Gwyn as if he was on a very
personal level with him he betrays his
thinking he betrays his secrets
and if calf is indeed loyal to the
world's logic as he says he is then it
follows that he was once all for Quinn's
age of light and maybe he even
encouraged Gwynn's war against the
ancient dragons the age of fire was
clearly dawning and back then it was
only logical that it be dominated by
beings of fire but next it was time for
dark to prevail after the advent of fire
the ancient Lords found the three souls
but your progenitor found a fourth
unique soul the Dark Soul your ancestor
claimed the Dark Soul and waited for
fire to subside thus began the age of
men the a
of dark that last line is actually
incorrect it suggests that the age of
dark began once but it didn't instead in
the Japanese text it goes on to say
eventually fire goes out and only dark
remains in that case it would be an age
of you humans of dark and it's true
living is a weakness and even the gods
who were persons of fire are no
exception to that rule but this age
never came to be
thanks to Gwyn Lord Gwyn feared the
logic of the world so he made his own
this was the first sin that stemmed from
humanity her name as she knows a freedom
for these are the roots of our world
cursed with undeath and relying on
kindling the fire to cure hollowing man
became intrinsically tied to Gwynn's age
of fire in time many even came to
believe in and love the cage of
falsehoods that had been created around
them the illusion of fools whose day on
ground
Gwyn even convinced a world serpent
frampt the king seeker that he alone had
changed the logic of the world so you
can imagine having a world serpent on
his side would have lent a lot of
credibility to his cause and in a way
frampt isn't wrong Gwyn did do
irreparable damage to the logic of the
world in retrospect we realized that he
ended up creating an age of fire so
endless that it ended up burning the
world down to ash
without ever truly passing over too dark
though frampt does experience a lapse of
faith when he witnesses the first Dark
Lord depose Gwyn
in the Norse myths Jormungandr the world
serpent is mortal enemies with Thor the
God of Thunder you can see the parallels
here so two discs are the world serpent
undermine Gwyn god of thunders rule in
Anor Londo and in all seal as well
new londo is of particular interest the
name new londo is clearly derived from
anor londo and if we go off the elvish
Sindarin translation anor londo
translates to Sun Haven making New Londo
is sort of young small haven the four
kings of New Londo were appointed by
Gwyn and they received fragments of his
very own soul and it's yet another
example of Gwyn sharing his authority
and his soul with others in his own
self-interests in addition to this point
the Japanese name of the four kings
suggests that instead of Kings they're
more like officials or at least public
Kings sort of ambassadors that were part
of Gwynn's overall plan for control as
for the ghosts in New Londo they align
with this common Japanese perception of
evil spirits resembling those who die in
a really sudden or violent manner people
who are not properly respected after
death and you know the residents of New
Londo were drowned on mass by the
healers in their community so they fit
that criteria because those were
supposed to be people they trusted even
the mountain of corpses below release
the heads of undead called a resentment
or a grudge which supports the idea that
the residents are bitter and vengeful at
how they were killed it also explains
how they were created and what a ghost
really represents in souls
there was definitely a decline in New
Londo society after kaif introduced
lifedrain to the four kings but it's
debatable whether it was actually cast
intention to drag the city into the
abyss because in the Japanese cough
clearly states that they meaning the
four kings failed him he says without
understanding the value of
Ruth they were merely conceited in their
power
he expected more from them he expected
them to pursue the truth not just steal
from others and this same disappointment
would apply to manases abyss in Aulis
he'll really while Kaif definitely said
to the EULA sealians habe manases
underneath your society and he is the
origin of all humans Golf himself admits
that all the seal brought the abyss upon
itself by defiling his grave Kaif didn't
necessarily intend for them to dig it up
and mess everything up it's definitely
clear that calf was trying to learn
about the world and he made mistakes as
he eventually worked towards his end
goal of usurping the fire and the most
success that he had was when he created
a sable church from the ground up with
its own ideology and its own goal
instead of just relying on others this
was more successful Kaif worked until
his dying breath till the very end
in the Japanese urea says he was as
devoted to the world's logic as Gwyn was
to defying it and there's this great
parallel with Norse mythology once again
your maganda
and Thor Kaif and Gwyn in both stories
both of them fall to one another at the
end of the world both stories are
identical in that way which is maybe
more than mere coincidence in the end
the world's logic doesn't go from light
to dark
it simply burns out and ash inherits the
world and with that in mind
who knows what awaits us if Dark Souls 4
is ever made I owe huge thanks for this
video to Loki who you've probably heard
about by now he's one of the best
writers I've ever met he was the
translator who contributed much of the
script this time around
I won't have as much time for
scriptwriting in the coming months I'm
sure some of you know why so instead of
making no videos at all I've simply
asked for a little bit of help I hope
you guys don't mind Thank You Loki and
thank you Perry God for the footage and
thank you as always for watching and
I'll see you next time
[Music]